>> Ready to answer?
>> These second graders in
Columbia, South Carolina are
about to come face-to-face
with a class
of second graders halfway
around the globe in Jordan.
>> Good morning, South Carolina.
>> Good morning, good morning.
>> This teleconference is just
part of the technology-rich,
twenty-first century curriculum
mix at Forest Lake Elementary.
>> We want you to meet
our Principal, Dr. Cannon.
>> Spearheaded by South
Carolina's elementary principal
of the year, Kappy Cannon.
>> Good morning!
>> Good morning girls and boys.
>> I don't think there's
a school in the world
where you have a
regular classroom
where everyone is
exactly the same.
Our school is a microcosm of
the world so we work very hard
to make sure that we
know where children are.
We don't take time to teach
things that they already know.
We try to go where they are
and take them as far as we can.
>> What are you working on?
>> Oh, I'm working on swamps.
>> If we all speak the same
language, that we're all
on the same page, when children
are getting the same messages
from all of us on what
our expectations are,
we know that they are going to
have much greater achievement.
>> Seventy-five percent
of us got that right.
>> Our focus is on
preparing children
for the twenty-first century.
We know that they have to have
science technology, engineering,
and mathematics to
be successful.
So we make sure that we
do have a shared vision
and that shared vision is
something that's always being
tweaked and changed a
little bit here and there
as we find our way to
making the best decisions
on behalf of students.
>> What's our challenge
this time?
What are we researching?
Yes, sir?
>> Classroom community is
something that's extremely
important and you can't build
a classroom community the first
week of school or the
first month of school.
It is an ongoing process.
>> Who can tell me what
we can tell by the graphs?
>> It's also something
developmentally
that the way it looks in
kindergarten might be different
than the way it looks
in fifth grade.
>> So that's what they're
going to be the experts about
and they're going to
present that to us.
>> But at the same time building
that culture of excellence
and having the personalization
with the students.
You know bottom line is this;
you can have all the tools
and all the bells and
whistles, all the technology,
but it's still is going
to boil down to one thing:
the relationship between
a teacher and the student.
>> Can you make someone else
feel great this morning?
Who would you like
to complement?
>> We have created our
own walk-through form
which is an observation,
it's not an evaluation.
And we call that our "failure
is not an option" form.
And what we did was we tried
to think of all the things
that we have worked on
in the past few years.
Maybe we've gone to a workshop,
it might be professional reading
that we have done,
conversations, staff
development.
Collectively put it all together
to make sure that we're doing
that we say that we're doing
and to stay focused
and to stay on track.
>> And you like spending
that time with him?
>> We also have times
during the years where all
of the teachers will go
in each other's classroom.
And again it's a
nonthreatening type of process
and you can get just that
one snapshot of going
in someone else's room and
seeing how they have taken some
of the same information
that you have been given
and they're using it
in a different way.
>> You are the best Arabian
knight I've ever seen.
>> Thank you.
>> You're just awesome, awesome.
>> If I were to advise
anyone on how to get started
with training it would be to
find those in your building
that have a natural
interest in technology
and invest in those folks.
And you really have to
be strategic with that
and it can't be a hit and miss.
>> Do you want to make
sure that you include that?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, good.
>> You need to select teachers
that are master teachers.
That doesn't mean
veteran teacher.
It means that it's a teacher
that is well-respected
by their peers and can ignite
the fire, the excitement
with other teachers and
then once it begins to grow,
you know, your job
as a principal is
to provide what it is
that they're asking
for because before you know
it you have a school full
of instructional leaders.
>> First we place in a light.
Was this experiencing
a day in the life of?
>> Anyone who does not hold
a classroom teacher position
in this building
including myself knows
that our number one job is to
support the classroom teachers
in what they're doing.
>> Who can think of a
question to go with our graph?
>> Teaching is one of
the most challenging
and rewarding professions,
and I think it's critical
that the administration
understands that,
not just by saying it
but truly understands
and respects what
they're doing every day.
>> Great try.
Let's see.
Is there anyone who would like
to help Juliana this morning?
>> For more information
on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org